I've created a JSON file with data for
each of the menu items.
These files are in the instructor notes.
The process to get a menu item's data is
almost exactly the same as what we just
did with menu.
When the URL is item/ some item name,
Ember calls the item route.
Again, we use the model
hook to fetch the data.
But how will Ember
know which item to get?
The item will be stored in item_name.
The model hook is passed
a params object and
we can get the item name
off of that object.
Now let's update the item template.
Just like updating the menu template,
we need to replace the static info
with the dynamic data
provided by the JSON file.
Remember that the data returned from
the model hook is stored in a model
variable.
And now we can finally
see the other menu items.
Awesome.
Have you noticed that clicking back and
forth, though, shows us a blank page for
a few seconds?
Let's fix that.
The problem is that we're using
an anchor tag to link to specific URLs
instead of letting Ember
manage the URLs for us.
Ember provides us a template
helper called link-to.
The link-to helper needs to know
which route it should link to.
We want this link to
link to the item route.
So item should go here.
The item route needs to have an item, so
we need to give one to
the link-to helper.
One thing that would trip me up in the
beginning is that this one needs quotes,
but this one doesn't, since it's
using the local item variable.
Using link-to with nested
routes is very similar.
Because the nutrition route
is nested inside item,
the route we need to reference in
the link-to helper is item.nutrition.
We don't need to worry about which item
to use, because to display the nutrition
template, we'll already
be on this item page.
Ember knows that and
handles that for us.
For more information
on the link-to helper,
check the link in the instructor notes.
Now there are no page refreshes and
all transitions are smooth and
instantaneous.
And what's cool is that the back
button works with all of this too.